hello everyone and welcome to the
shortest game I've ever shown in the
channel not so long ago we've shown a
game that featured only four moves
however this game features even less and
as I'm getting a lot of messages as to
what happened here I decided just to
show it and well explain what happened
so here it's the second game of the
semifinals of the chasuble Masters 2020
dink had the white pieces and he opened
with c4 so he went for the English
opening Magnus went for East six with g3
and Queen to g5 now so an early
development of the Queen
ding went for Bishop to G 2 he just been
in care of his life score bishop and
here we reached the position from the
thumbnail Magnus just played Queen
captures on b2 and it was also in this
position after being captured at that
Magnus Carlsen resigned the game ok so
it is four moves the Bishop captures his
four moves but the reason why Magnus did
this and why he resigned is because in
the first game
ding lost the first game however ding
lost in a in a completely drawn row
component game due to the the disconnect
issue so his internet got disconnected
and that's why Magnus won that game and
he did not want to Magnus did not want
to continue at the match being up a
point in you know it is III mean it is
according to the rules you have to have
like a super steady connection if you're
playing such an elite tournament and you
have to take care of that but Magnus
didn't want I didn't want to have a lead
in the match that he got by by being
disconnecting so in so he just sacrifice
the Queen on the move three and then
resigned the game so the match can just
continue from again unequal grounds so I
thought as a lot of you guys are asking
me what happened and it is well really
an act of a true gentleman I decided to
show it and feature this move as it's
definitely you know maybe it's not the
way to the top but maybe it actually is
as you know a lot of people will see
this and it will maybe inspire a lot of
people to also you know act accordingly
in situations like these so that's the
game I do hope you enjoy that we are
going
to continue of course with the match
with with more games to come but now
there are an evil evil not evil equal
grounds and well we'll see what happens
if this you know brings brings out the
best in both of them or will Magnus you
know be sorry for doing this but I don't
think he would be sorry even if he loses
the match today but yeah I would like to
thank Victor Gannon I feel Eastlake
Peter Rasmussen Kevin Johnson and Stefan
Lin pointer a pointer for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the chasuble
masters with some longer games see you
soon guys